welcome to my ultimate cookery course
packed with quick cooking tips know-how
and 100 recipes to take your life on now
it's all about real fast food
[Music]
real fast food should always grab your
attention with big gutsy flavors
fantastic aromas and be immediately
satisfying
it should also be easy to make and quick
to cook and real fast food doesn't get
much faster than my first dish
chicken stir fry with rice noodles some
of the best street food i've ever eaten
was in asia every one of those little
markets was filled with smells of
delicious food that all centered around
an asian staple noodles learn to cook
those properly and you'll be surprised
how quick and easy it is to knock off a
delicious dinner
first off we're gonna soak our noodles
now these are rice noodles into a bowl
and just pour the hot water
over the rice noodles
soak
and rehydrate
12 to 15 minutes to soften up if you've
got a wok perfect if not just a normal
size frying pan with big sloping sides
pan on
get it really nice and hot
chicken breast very lean hardly any fat
on there you've got this little fillet
just slice that off
now the secret to getting it really nice
and thin
and to cut it into strips
take your knife
keep it nice and flat on the board and
sort of slice it in half like a sort of
scallop
like that
we call this butterfly in the chicken
take a rolling pin
and nice and gently roll over the
chicken what it does it sort of flattens
it allows you to slice it
even thinner
and the thinner the slices of the
chicken
the sort of crispier it gets the quicker
it cooks
slice it in half
just start slicing
these nice
thin slices and the good news is one
chicken breast can serve two or three
easily next wash your knife and finally
slice garlic
the thinner the garlic
the crispier
this is a
young
tender
broccoli just slice them down i want a
bite to the broccoli
and normally you sort of paste the dish
with one-third noodles one-third
vegetables and one-third of your protein
chicken
with a dish that takes literally minutes
to put together it's really important to
get everything organized everything
needs to be at your fingertips
touch
of olive oil
get a pan really nice and ready
just starting to smoke drop the chicken
in first
salt pepper
open up those little strands of chicken
nice
once you've started to sear off the
chicken
get the garlic in
now let that get really nice and crispy
the way to do it is to sort of spread
all the chicken the garlic up the side
of the pan
and see why it's so important to cut the
chicken thin strips because it colors
and cooks at the same time as well
really really crucial
now that garlic's getting really nice
and crispy broccoli in
feels strange putting raw broccoli
in like that normally
we'll blanch it in boiling water dry it
out but
you want that crunch
now soy sauce that helps to season it
but also stains beautifully soy sauce in
lovely that's exactly what i want now
take that out
give your pan a little wipe out
a little teaspoon of olive oil get that
wok
really nicely oiled again
drain your noodles
they're beautiful
this is a really exciting way of
finishing
this quick stir fry very classic two
eggs
in
whisk up the eggs
and give that a really good whisk
[Music]
sort of almost
spread it
at the side of the pan
lightly season
the eggs
noodles
in
chicken and broccoli in
[Music]
and give that
a really nice mix
you want the egg to sort of almost
bring the dish together
that egg's cooked
make sure you've got that nice
even distribution of
chicken
broccoli
garlic
lovely
and then just finish that fresh lime
and then you have a very
simple
delicious stir-fry with rice noodles
[Music]
noodles are a fast food staple and they
come in all shapes and sizes they're so
easy to cook healthy but really
delicious here are three effortless
recipes that are ready literally in
minutes
first up noodle soup with poached egg
and spring onions
[Music]
add miso paste to boiling water
japanese miso has a wonderful deep
savoury richness and is brilliant in
soups
grating fresh ginger
add dry shiitake mushrooms that have
been soaked in water
season with soy sauce
an egg add it to the broth and poach for
two to three minutes
add thinly sliced portobello mushrooms
to a serving bowl
put in fresh medium egg noodles which
will heat through in the hot meso broth
add spinach
[Music]
then simply spoon the broth into your
bowl
top with the egg
and fresh chopped spring onions
so simple so good and so delicious ready
in 10 minutes super fast noodle soup
with poached egg and spring onions
my next easy dish using the versatile
noodle is stir fried pork noodles
first marinade pork mince and shaoxing
rice wine a fortified chinese wine
soy sauce
and sesame oil
next fry chopped ginger in hot olive oil
and garlic
[Music]
next add szechuan peppercorns which have
a wonderful lemony flavor and gives a
pleasant tingling sensation
now add your marinated pork mince
and brown
if you want more seasoning and extra soy
sauce
then add fiery chili bean paste
and rice wine vinegar
[Music]
add in cooked egg noodles
mix together
finally top with chopped spring onion
and toasted sesame seeds
[Music]
packed with flavor and on the table in
15 minutes delicious stir-fried pork
noodles
[Music]
my next noodle dish you can knock up in
no time is
noodles with chili ginger and lemongrass
[Music]
add chopped onions to hot olive oil
garlic
chili
and fry
grating ginger
next lemongrass first bash it with a
knife doing this will help release this
wonderful lemony flavour and scent
now aromatic kaffir lime leaves then
ground cumin coriander and turmeric
next add cream coconut
chicken stock
fish sauce
and simmer
soak rice vermicelli noodles in hot
water
drain
[Music]
and add to your serving bowl
pour over the aromatic soup broth
finish with coriander
and chopped chili
on the table in around 20 minutes
noodles with chili ginger and lemongrass
real fast food
fast healthy delicious three
mouth-watering recipes guaranteed to
help you master the art of incredible
tasting noodles
next five more of my 100 top tips to
make your home cooking easier
first up how to join the chicken for
your favorite real fast food dishes
open up
the legs and just pierce the skin there
careful not to cut into the breast
and hand on top of the breast and pull
the drum back
pop out
and then slice the knife
straight across
there's the thigh there's the drum get
your thumb and feel
the joint and with the weight of the
knife just slices through now two
beautiful thighs
now a bit of a chef's tip halfway down
the drum just slice through
onto the bone
and then from there
scrape the tendons
and then
hand down nice and firm on top
now
i'll get this beautiful bone
presentation as it cooks it cooks evenly
now pull out the wing
feel where the end of the joint is and
just slice in there
through
a beautiful big whole delicious wing
now
this
is the rolls-royce part two breasts
that's the breast bone there
place the chicken on the board and then
just slice down on the back of the crown
everyone always cuts around just tilt it
upwards
straight through that way we get
straight to the center of the carcass
and therefore there's no waste
and look
we end up taking off his plump
chicken breasts
nice
two drums two thighs two wings
two breasts of chicken and one amazing
carcass for a stock and not an ounce of
waste
a great tip to stop your skewers burning
when you're making kebabs is to soak
them in water first or for skewers with
added flavor strip your rosemary
branches of their leaves and use instead
[Music]
for no fuss marinading my tip is to
place fish or meat in a plastic storage
bag while they marinate it's easy to
store and there's less cleanup
lime juice or lemon juice make great
marinades my tip for getting maximum
amount of juice from a lemon or lime is
to roll it hard under your palm for a
minute before juicing
lemons are also useful for rice add a
couple of drops of juice while you cook
it to keep your grains looking nice
white and bright
this is my ultimate cookery course 100
recipes to stake your life on
i'll be showing you how to make
mouth-watering burgers with a difference
pork is perfect for a slider but i want
a little bite in there
but first my guide to getting the best
ingredients for your money
whether i'm knocking out fast food or
planning a feast i want my dishes to be
the tastiest they can be and to do that
i always start with the best ingredients
i can get
my shopping manta is very simple
knowledge is crucial the more you know
personally about where your ingredients
are from and how they produce the better
so ask lots of questions and learn
[Applause]
here's a quick rundown of the six most
useful vinegars and what you can do with
them
all my great fast and easy dressings
with the exception of malt vinegar use
this for pickling or splashing on your
fish and chips
tangy red wine vinegar is great for
marinades red meats and card liver
white wine vinegar is good for sweet and
sour recipes as well as butter sauces
cherry vinegar nutty and virgin on the
sweet side this perfect splash into
gazpacho or team with sweet seasoned veg
like asparagus or artichokes
while cider vinegar tart and fruity is
ideal for pickling fruit and for
vegetable chutneys
rice vinegar is an essential for chinese
and japanese dishes and is lovely and
mild in flavor
balsamic vinegar widely considered as
the king of vinegars is the one i use
time and time again dark and syrupy its
sweet and sharp taste is a great
addition if you're frying juicy steaks
or chops in marinades or on fresh sweet
strawberries
like fine wine the price reflects the
time it's been matured anywhere between
three and 25 years
look out for the stamp to make sure
you're getting the genuine article from
italy's modern region
you can pay up to 200 quid for just 100
mils of top quality balsamic vinegar
like this one
and if you do splash out on one of the
fine types you'll have to taste it to
believe it
[Music]
there's a wealth of classic fast food
dishes we know and love from hot dogs
and kebabs to tacos and burgers but the
great thing about making them at home is
you can throw away the rule book and get
creative
my next easy recipe is a miniature
version of an american favorite the
burger smoky pork sliders with barbecue
sauce
everyone loves a burger they're a true
fast food original and that's the
exciting thing about street food you can
take an old classic like that and
reinvent it into something really
exciting
when you think of a burger what you need
is a great sauce an unlike smoky
barbecue it goes hand in glove with a
great burger
start by finely chopping one onion and
three cloves of garlic
nice hot pan tablespoon of olive oil
onions and garlic into the pan
nice seasoning salt and pepper
now the secret of a good barbecue sauce
is that really important caramelization
to begin with a nice tablespoon of brown
sugar
it darkens the onions but it really
starts to sort of give that nice syrupy
body to the sauce
i'll put a little bit of heat in there
now a nice teaspoon of smoked paprika
that's the important part of working
with spices you've got to cook them out
and almost sort of burn off that rawness
especially with a smoked paprika that's
exactly where i want it to go
onions and garlic beautifully
caramelized
cider vinegar in
reduce that down
now i've got a fantastic smoky base to
complete the sauce i'm making my life
really easy and adding pre-made
worcester sauce and tomato ketchup cook
that out for two to three minutes
now depending on how thick you like the
barbecue sauce that determines how long
you cook it out for i don't want it to
be too
runny but i don't want it too thick
either
that's the consistency we're looking for
lovely
turn down the gas
charger seasoning
now
take that out
it's the kind of sauce that i like to
have sort of bottled up in the fridge
it's great for sandwiches
but goes brilliantly well with these
sliders
homemade smoky barbecue sauce
[Music]
give the pan a little wipe
now start the mix for the sliders to
give my mix a really interesting flavor
and texture i'm gonna be using unsmoked
back bacon i
travel
all over the world
and i spend a lot of time in the states
they know how to make a great slider
pork sliders beef sliders chicken
sliders and it's almost like a way of
having a burger
but on a much smaller miniature level
a little teaspoon of olive oil
i want that bacon to get really nice and
crispy
bacon in this just gives the really nice
sort of chunky delicious mix i want
texture
and pork is perfect for a slider
[Music]
and choppy shallots
slots are a lot sweeter than your normal
white onion
fine fine fine and in
[Music]
now that bacon's getting really nice and
crispy i want a bit of heat in there a
little teaspoon
of smoked paprika in there
when you see these sliders in the states
for one portion there's like four or
five of them little mini
one biters incredible
now take your pork
just open up
and give that a really nice seasoning
so important you can't season a slider
after you've cooked it it's impossible
so
season it nicely
bacon now that's nice and crispy
just take a little touch
kitchen roll and just drain that off
there
nice
pat that
nice and dry i want all that nice sort
of crispiness
in there
beautiful mix all that
in
take
a nice ball and sort of
roll it
size of a golf ball
get it nice and round first and then
three fingers
just pat that down
don't flatten them too thin otherwise
they overcook and they go
sort of dry
because sliders are bite-sized burgers
designed to go in small buns you don't
want to make them too big
good
get the pan nice and hot
a tablespoon of olive oil
when a slider is literally that thick
about an inch thick
we're going to take two and a half to
three minutes to each side
in
turn them over
lovely
once you've turned them tilt the pan and
just spoon
all that juice back into them
keep my mouth watering now
very easy to dry the pork out so just
feeling it now with your fingers is nice
and firm
it's a little touch of springiness in
the center i'm happy with those
add your cheese now so it gets nicely
melted
i'm using wedgies of smoked cheddar
and it has that nice sort of soury smoky
creaminess to the slider
finally shredded baby gem lettuce
just take those buns
make sure they're sliced
nice and evenly
take your lettuce be quite generous with
the lettuce
just a nice thin slice
of tomato
take your burgers
you see that cheese
if you've melted your barbecue sauce
place the top on
and that is my version of a slider that
is small dynamic but packed full of
flavor i'll take that over a hamburger
any day
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stake your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking
welcome to my ultimate cookery course
packed with quick cooking tips know-how
and 100 recipes to take your life on
right this is my guide to amazing home
cooked street food classics
[Music]
street food gets its name because it's
cooked and eaten on the streets from the
hawker marcus in asia to the new york
hot dog stands there are some great
chefs out there serving seriously
delicious food that you can eat on the
go
my first recipe is a special mix of
fantastic flavors from around the world
beef tacos with wasabi mayo
the great thing about street food is
anything goes the only rule is they've
got to be really fast and really tasty
now these tacos mix are mexican and
japanese flavors into a delicious meaty
mouthful
first off get that pan really nice and
hot
these are
sirloin steaks
sear it in the pan with all that fat on
i'll add flavor
salt and pepper
couple tablespoons of olive oil in
pan
nice and hot
hold up the steak
and lay it in always lay away
give the pan a
little shake and it stops the steak from
sticking we're looking for color
and if it sticks it's gonna burn
[Music]
while the steaks are cooking i can get
on with my super quick marinade
now
two tablespoons of
misood paste that's a fermented soybean
that gives a really nice sort of rich
sweetness
tablespoon of sugar
a couple of tablespoons rice wine that
gives it a really nice vinegary
kick a couple of tablespoons of olive
oil
salt and pepper
i'm looking for a nice sort of thick
rich marinade
marinade done it's time to turn the
steaks
sort the pan
and to give the steaks a little base all
we're doing every time is just adding
more and more flavor
take your tongs and sort of lift the
steak on its back and really
melt all that fat down
offer the gas
take them out
just take your knife
see all that fat there just slice that
off
i don't want any of that
now
in
to the marinade
[Music]
beautiful
tacos are one of mexico's most popular
street foods they've been made from beef
pork chicken or fish and are loaded up
with amazing sauces and spices
now i want something sort of pickly
cabbage
these are
um chinese cabbages slice it in half
look at it really crisp and really tasty
we're gonna slice that into quarters
and then just shred it and take your
time
you think of cabbage here and you think
of sort of braised
overcooked cabbage nothing worse
but at a taco you want freshness
a little season of chili flakes
they sort of discreetly
give it a little bit of heat
a little touch
of rice wine vinegar
if you haven't got that
fresh lemon juice
a small drop of toasted sesame seed oil
give that
a really good mix now i need something
to sort of bring it together we take
some wasabi paste very hot very spicy a
sort of thumbnail size
i'm gonna mix that
with a couple of tablespoons of
mayonnaise
and give that a really good mix
these are basic corn tortilla the trick
is
to sort of color them
and then shape them actually place it
on
the gas ring
use some tongs
so it's not to burn yourself
you can also toast your tacos in a
frying pan
from there
i'm just gonna place it
on the rolling pin
literally 30 seconds
as it cools down
the great thing about serving tacos is
people can fill them themselves just the
way they want them
cabbage
just squeeze out wet marinade
a nice rustic little mountain
mayonnaise
on
wait you see
how soft
and delicious and almost sort of
melting in the mouth texture we've got
on this amazing sirloin
it's look at that really nice
sear around the outside
it's just nice and pink in the middle
start off with my
crispy shell
back of the spoon with the wasabi
mayonnaise
inside
taco
and just sprinkle
that delicious
pickled cabbage
and then just
start lining my tacker with three or
four slices
touch more
on my spicy
layer
that is how i'd make
the perfect taco
[Music]
when you want comfort food quick fast
food classics always deliver here are
three more of my street food favorites
all super easy but still put the gourmet
into grab-and-go
this street food dish packs a wonderful
indian influence
subtly spiced chicken wrap
grab a mortar and pestle to make a spicy
marinade for the chicken
crack open cardamom pods and add
ground ginger
coriander
cinnamon
grated nutmeg
cloves of garlic
fresh coriander
lemon juice
olive oil
and season
now pulverize to form a paste
pour over the chicken thighs and leave
to marinade for up to two hours
to cook griddle on a high heat to get
wonderfully charred meat
[Music]
once the chicken is cooked warm through
tortilla wraps on the same griddle
then simply slice your chicken
and put your wrap together
top with shredded cabbage
chopped spring onion
and your favorite chilli sauce
ready in 20 minutes sticky succulent and
utterly moorish spiced chicken wrap
you'll find my next fast food classic
all over america tasty chili dogs
[Music]
for super quick and easy beef chili
add chopped onions to hot olive oil and
cook until soft
then add chopped garlic
a teaspoon of cumin seeds and stir to
release their lovely aromatic flavor
next chili powder
turn up the heat and break beef mince
into the pan
brown and season
add tomato puree and cook through
next i'd like a spicy worcestershire
sauce
chopped in tomatoes
dried oregano
add a sprinkle of sugar
[Music]
cook frankfurter or bratwurst sausages
bung in a bun
and simply top with a spicy beef chili
[Music]
easy and irresistible a dog worth
crossing the street for
my third street food inspired recipe is
vietnamese style baguette with beef
start slicing sirloin steak into strips
then simply marinade in soy sauce the
salty
and runny honey the sweet
and leaf up to two hours
then thread your marinated beef strips
onto skewers
and pan fry in hot olive oil
for the topping which adds a lovely sour
contrast great carrot and simply leave
to pickle in rice vinegar
[Music]
next make the easy dressing
simply de-seed and chop a chili
add caster sugar and lime juice
add a glug of fish sauce
slice a baguette
when lovely and brown the marinaded
steak skewers are done
remove and add
top with the pickled carrot
add cool sliced cucumber
drizzle over the spicy dressing
and to finish it off add coriander
leaves
simple to make but complex in flavor
absolutely delicious
[Music]
three stunning recipes from the streets
to your home guaranteed to take food on
the run to a whole new level
and so simple to do
[Music]
you don't need to spend a fortune on
masses of kitchen equipment
here's my quick guide to another cooking
essential
frying pan
for me one of my favorites why because
it's so versatile whether you're searing
the most amazing rack of lamb cooking
duck breasts sauteing chicken or even a
quick omelet or even find an egg
all in one
look for an oven-proof frying pan with a
metal handle if you want to cook like
pros by finishing off your dish in the
oven or under a hot grill just don't
forget when you take it out the handle
will be hot
if you can get a high quality non-stick
one with a thick heavy base which will
distribute the heat evenly
brilliant
welcome back to my ultimate cookery
course
next on my guide to street food
i'll be whipping up an indulgent
finger-licking treat that is amazing
but first
like any passionate chef i want the best
ingredients i can find whether it's for
savory
or sweet dishes
next up my guide to buying chocolate
chocolate gives you such an instant hit
it's well worth knowing about the good
stuff
and who better to ask than award-winning
alchemist of the sweetest kind paul
young even when i don't want to think
about it i'm thinking about it
his cutting-edge approach to chocolate
making has won him accolades around the
world
so when you're not shopping the best way
is to look at your chocolate bar look on
the back and look at the percentage that
gives you how much cocoa is in the bar
and the more cocoa the more rich
intoxicating flavor so the most exciting
bit is tasting chocolate
good quality fine chocolate should have
that clean snap bite a piece off
and crunch it in your teeth
but stop chewing
let it melt
move it around the mouth and you'll find
that by letting it melt
even dark chocolate that you've had
before
that seems quite bitter won't be when
you chew quickly it releases tannin it
releases all the bitterness in the
chocolate letting it melt it's smoother
and richer and you get all the flavor
and most excitingly is it releases
something into the brain called dopamine
which makes you feel good
and that's how you get addicted to real
chocolate
chocolate is not just an addictive treat
it's an amazing ingredient here's my
take on which kind to use for what
[Music]
white chocolate with its sweet vanilla
taste is perfect used as a dipping or
pouring sauce with fresh fruit or frozen
berries for a quick dessert
creamy milk chocolate is great for
family friendly puddings and treats like
quick bake cakes or melt onto homemade
crepes or waffles
dark chocolate is rich and intense i
like using 70 coco stuff use it for ice
creams that really pack a punch
100 pure cocoa has a very powerful
intense taste and only the real
chocolate geeks eat it straight and
remember chocolate isn't just for sweet
dishes for the famous mexican molay
sauce this is the one to grab
is there anything better than chocolate
they say sex but that's totally
overrated
chocolate is a key ingredient in my
favorite sweet fast food dishes which at
their best are always irresistible
instant and utterly satisfying
so when you want an indulgent chocolate
hit my next recipe will be right up your
alley
malt chocolate donuts street food is all
about satisfying your cravings these
donuts are sweet sticky and absolutely
delicious
first off we're gonna make the dough
now
this dough takes a bit of time
but it's really exciting
i'm heating all of the milk with the
sugar
this yeast
easy to get hold of now when you make
fresh donuts
you need fresh yeast
adding some of the warm milk to the
yeast will activate it which will help
the dough to rise
just half
give that a quick whisk
the sugar sugar's dissolved in the milk
the fresh yeast disintegrates instantly
set the yeast mixture to one side while
it does its job
to start the main dough mix i'm adding
half the butter to the remaining milk
that gives the dough a nice silkiness i
want it light
so melt the butter into the milk
flour
into a sieve that helps to make the
dough nice and smooth and you know when
you've got a smooth dough
it sort of rises evenly
add a pinch of salt and two egg yolks
pour in the warm milk and melted butter
don't start over mixing it
when you over mix
the dough of a doughnut it gets really
tight you're not gonna let it ariel
yeast in
nice and warm
i love that smell
now i'm looking for a sort of elasticy
texture just dropping off the spoon
nice flour the board
take the dough out
lovely
lightly sprinkle touch more flour
and just pull it over and push in
every time you're sort of turning it
almost like you're turning the dough
into itself the dough should just sort
of relax
it shouldn't be sticking to your fingers
now it's just nice and pliable
set that in a nice clean bowl
a little sprinkling
flour in there so as it starts to rise
it doesn't stick
cover that with some film
leave the dough to rise in a warm place
for 60 to 90 minutes until it's doubled
in size this stage is called proving
now whilst that's proving get a panel
for the chocolate filling or ganache
pour 500 mils of double cream into a
saucepan and add honey
[Music]
bring the mixture to a gentle boil
[Music]
traditionally we always put jam in there
but chocolate and donuts wow to die for
add the cream
i'll give that a good mix
the butter elevates the ganache into a
really nice
shiny chocolate coat
look at that whoa
give it a really nice whisk
the whistling gives it that aerated
texture to the ganache you're just
lightening the load a little bit
nice
chocolate filling done
put it in the fridge to cool then it's
time to gently roll out the dough
just let it roll naturally about a
centimetre and a half in depth
slice
one
two
place them on to your tray
and let them rise again once the donors
have had 30 to 40 minutes to rise it's
time to shallow fry them in a pan filled
one third full with hot vegetable oil
risen but look they're sort of
like little pockets of air
right here we go
place these in nice and carefully
four
maximum if there's too many in the pan
the oil will go cold and the donuts will
come out
soggy turn them over
beautiful
[Music]
they're gonna come out into some sugar
mixed with some malt powder
50 50.
how do you tell they're actually cooked
in the center
tap on top should be hollow
in
and just sprinkle
the malt
and the sugar
shake off
the excess i get so excited every time i
make donuts
now
look at those beauties
these are delicious eating as they are
but the ganache is gonna be the icing on
the cake
piping bag
peel the bag
over your hand
don't forget to pop the nozzle in
i want the texture
almost like a little liquid inside
so i'm going gonna pipe them on a little
bit warm hopefully with that burst of
magic
operation donut
lift up
the donut
squeeze push in and fill
just to start seeing that chocolate
coming out
and sit that back down
nice
sit them on there
they've got a little bit heavier and we
all know why
nice
that one's got my name on it
that is amazing
[Music]
next my tricks of the trade and kitchen
tips
starting with how to do your steak the
way you want it
i want to cook my steak rare so by
touching the steak i want the same
feedback
as it is on the inside of my thumb
that's rare
as it starts to cook it gets a lot
firmer
medium is there semi-firm with a slight
resistance well done it's there
rare
a great tip for getting meat or fish to
cook faster is to score it which allows
the heat to penetrate quicker this also
allows marinades to be absorbed more
deeply
for stain free tupperware
coat it thinly with oil which acts as a
barrier between plastic and food
it's so easy to make your own chili
sherry to use in quick stir-fries or
sauces take 450 ml of dry sherry such as
fino and using a funnel pour into a
sterilised bottle
add five whole thai chilies seal with a
cork or lid and leave to infuse for a
couple of weeks
my tip for using any discarded chili
seeds is plant them to grow yourself
some new chili peppers plant in an egg
shell or seedling trays start them
indoors and move outside when they're
ready
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stake your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking
you